this is dave klein reading for steve
watts
super mario striker's battle league may
be based on soccer but from the looks of
a hands-off live preview it appears to
be taking some liberal notes from
american football from the name battle
league to the heavily armored gear to
the mushroom kingdom residents striking
poses with what can only be described as
tude this appears to be an enjoyably
irreverent way to toughen up the sport
it starts with a selection of stadiums
in which two different arenas are
smashed together at the midfield line
making a functional hybrid of both these
fields may have some minor size
differences but the main point is the
visual satisfaction of watching huge
land masses crash into one another then
the players take the field looking
angrier and more determined than they
ever have even when a giant lizard
kidnapped their quasi girlfriend the
overall impression seems to be that this
is soccer but bad
but also mario it's very silly then the
game starts and it's mostly a
straightforward 4v4 soccer match the
relatively small roster players have
different stats like power and speed
though some fields on the smaller side
seem to erase the speed difference
between a bruiser like bowser and a
lighter character like yoshi goalies on
both sides are the boom boom from mario
3 you can pass and shoot occasionally
taking a detour to collect question
blocks that appear on the field where it
distinguishes itself most from a regular
soccer match are with the special shots
which can be delivered after a team has
built up sufficient power these are the
blue shell of mario striker's battle
league albeit with a little more skill
involved when you activate a power shot
a swinging meter will appear similar to
ones you've seen in mario golf games or
2000's mario strikers charged pulling
off perfect timing launches an
unblockable shot and guarantees you his
score while less than perfect timing
makes the shot difficult but still
possible to stop
these special moves look nicely
differentiated too each highlighting a
character's unique traits they're also a
cool visual flourish showing elements of
the sketchy ink style that appears in
the official artwork the character's
post-gold celebrations as seen through a
cinematic and replay camera are a fun
touch the thin roster looks to put that
much more emphasis on gear to
differentiate your playstyle like the
special shots this is a nice visual
touch that incorporates each character's
style mario's headgear options for
example are a series of different armor
takes on his iconic hat they each come
with stat boost so you can tweak your
players to your liking and this seems to
be where the game's economy comes most
into play as you purchase new pieces of
gear with coins earned during play you
can also customize your soccer club with
things like different fence posts and
decorations managing your club is part
of the backdrop of competitive play as
you'll make your own club identity by
picking a logo from a series of icons
background shields and colors and you'll
be competing for seasonal ranks with
rank points coming whether you win or
lose but bigger rewards for a win you
can start taking the feel now with the
first kick demo which covers the
training section of the game and is
available for nintendo switch online
members and as was the case with both
mario tennis aces and mario golf super
rush nintendo has also announced plans
for multiple free content drops that
will add additional characters
post-launch mario striker's battle
league releases for nintendo switch on
june 10.
[Music]